[Musique]
et c'est avec vous Michel midoro bonsoir
bonsoir on commence avec cette
information ce matin le château de
Versailles a une nouvelle fois été
évacué pour des raisons de sécurité
effectivement Mathilde il s' gérit d'une
nouvelle alerte à la bombe qui a
entraîné l'évacuation de près de 2000
visiteurs à 10h20 le château a pu
rouvrir en début d'après-midi depuis
quelques mois le monument est visé par
ce type d'alerte pour rappel au mois
d'octobre 7 FO salertes ont eu lieu en
seulement 8 jours on va parler de
politique à présent et notamment de la
loi immigration la loi immigration a été
adopté hier soir ce texte prévoit
d'instaurer des quotas migratoires et
des cartes de séjour délivré
automatiquement pour les métiers en
tension tel que le secteur du bâtiment
et de l'aide à domicile les négociations
autour de cette loi ont été agitées dans
les iines tous les députés de la
majorité ont approuver ce texte sauf
nadiae elle estime que la proposition
finale de la loi est trop ferme et trop
peu sensible au aux problématiques
vécues par les personnes étrangères et
la plateforme parcours sup a ouvert ce
midi oui mais attention les choix
d'orientations se feront seulement à
partir du 17 janvier pour l'instant
seule la consultation des 23000
formations est possible les élèves de
terminal et pour la première fois ceux
de seconde peuvent profiter des
nouveautés que le site propose la
version 2024 permet notamment de
comparer les formations automatiquement
vous retrouverez également sur le site
les dates des prochaines portes ouvertes
qui vous intéressent
et enfin on termine ces informations par
une innovation unique en France une
innovation unique en France qui
permettra peut-être une 5G plus
performante dans les ivelines le
Laboratoire national de métrologie et
DCL LNE situé ATT trrape a décidé de
collaborer avec Nexio une entreprise
spécialisée dans
l'électromagnétisme ce partenariat a
donné naissance au laboratoire
radiofréquence mais alors qu'est-ce que
c'est il s'agit d'un laboratoire qui
permettra d'avoir une communication plus
rapide et à terme d'avoir la 6G Mathilde
plusieurs secteurs sont concernés dont
l'industrie le médical le transport
ferroviaire aéronautique et l'automobile
bien merci beaucoup Mel midoro pour
toutes ces informations et comme
d'habitude si vous aussi vous voyez une
image ou une information qui vous a
marqué pr près de chez vous n'hésitez
pas à nous la partager sur les réseaux
sociaux en utilisant le hashtag 78 news